doozy asked us to make vlogs i've never
made one before and i had no idea what
to make it about so i just thought i
would make it about an average day for
myself
i hope you enjoy
i don't really dream when i sleep all
that much or remember them anyway alarm
goes off at about 9 15.
get some organic turmeric cinnamon tea
going
put that in the cup get a little green
tea going in there put that in the cup
and i start making my oatmeal you got
blackberries blueberries you got some
strawberries put some cinnamon on that
and
some flaxseed then you put in the
oatmeal
then i take a few seconds to think about
the fact that aliens are here and no one
gives a [ __ ] and then the tea is ready
water
put it in there hot water on the tea put
the lid on the tea hot water in the
oatmeal
then i do this every morning i don't
really know why pat the oatmeal down
maybe it's to lock in the flavor i'm not
sure
i always end that with a
slice into the oatmeal with the spoon
like a sword
consume the oatmeal as quickly as
possible
biggest bites i can take when i get the
fuel in
so i can begin my day
try not to waste any more time
then the tea is ready take that out
then it's time to hit the cans the cans
are some paint cans that i attach to a
wooden curtain rod during the pandemic
because i couldn't find any free weights
they were sold out everywhere
but i still use the cans
getting a little
brief workout before beginning
work itself this is where i work
i got my chair my setup my table
my computer
my t
this is what it looks like if you're my
computer
i'm currently working on a sitcom about
aliens coming to earth to save humanity
from nuclear war
and it's about two families in texas as
all that's happening
i'll break it up by doing some
card shuffling
and weird card [ __ ] that i started
watching a bunch of youtube videos about
during the pandemic and it just kind of
stuck now it's like my my fidget toy i
can't not do that with one hand then
it's time for lunch with my pot and my
pan
and you put some
vegetable broth in that pot you put some
lentils in that pot you put some
tomatoes in that pot you grate an entire
root of turmeric into that pot
you blend up some cumin and some black
pepper put that in the pot then you turn
on the heat on the pot then you go to
the pan you put in some olive oil you
put in some no soy soy sauce
you put in some mushrooms you put in
some of those brussels sprouts
you put in some of those onions you turn
the heat on the pan now you put in some
cabbage put in some carrots kale
spinach
radishes
orange bell peppers green onions
broccoli garlic
stir all that around stir around
everything in the pot it's cooking while
it's all cooking i eat a little piece of
a beet that's pretty good
then you take everything from the pan
put it in the pot stir it all up and
this is the gruel this is what i eat
every day
and you take a bite you never know how
it's going to turn out but today
the grill was pretty good it was a
pretty good batch then after lunch i
take a bath hot water only
then it is back to the cans
then it is back to work
then i take a little break and i do some
reading i'm right now reading this book
and then i do some more work
and then i do some more cans
and then i do some more work
and then i do some more card [ __ ]
just to get the blood pumping get up out
of the chair
and do some more work
do some more cans
and eventually night falls and i can
emerge unafraid that the poisonous sun
will melt my face again and i go for a
little jog i like to jog at night like
this because as you can see there's
nobody in the street you can just walk
right in the middle of the [ __ ]
street there's no cars or anything
coming
[ __ ] love it
then i come back
take my next bath
pop two melatonin get in bed watch a
little anime this is how not to summon a
demon lord i'm watching that one right
now
and then i fade into the blackness of a
dreamless sleep and that's my entire day
you